[Music]
regardless of what game they play
every top fps competitor has hit a clip
at one point or another that
just looks us you've seen this happen
a million times sometimes someone hits a
shot
so insane it just feels like it can't be
real
so this week we wanted to take a look at
the crazy plays that got pros accused of
cheating
whether or not the accusations were
legitimate
some were innocent some have been proven
guilty
and for others we still don't know but
before we get into that
i just want to remind you guys to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
done so already that way you'll never
miss a video
just like this one and with that let's
get into the top 10
sus plays in esports history
kicking off our list we've got sub rosa
before he became the sky main that
everyone knows and loves
subrosa was playing cs go just like
nearly
every other valor pro and back in cs go
he had a history of doing some pretty
strange
things on the server
some of his shots just look well suss
and it didn't take too long for people
online to wonder if saroza was
actually cheating but no clip looks more
suspicious than his truly bizarre flick
onto skadoodle
who was hiding behind boxes at northern
arena back in 2016
once again reddit called for savrosa's
head and although there was never clear
evidence that he was cheating
even some of his peers began questioning
a few clips
i don't think i i surely don't want
hacking i think
i think he's just a finesse who can aim
to this day
it's unproven whether or not sabrosa
actually cheated
but given he's been around for so long
it seems pretty unlikely
grappling his way into the number nine
spot we've got one of overwatch's dps
gods taimou this rip tire could change a
lot of things that's going to find
oh it's not going to find an area taimou
got him right after the jedi from dia
self-destruct harry hook hides behind
the pillar stays alive in time who says
you know what that's it i'm done i'm
going to just kill everybody
following a victory versus rogue in ogn
overwatch apex season one
a reddit user suggested that taimou was
aimbotting because his aim looked a
little
too snappy when the opposing team's
mercy resurrected their down
teammate mcqueen mercy
on me in the back okay
team envy co-owner mike castro ruffalo
came to taimou's defense and stated that
when he joined the team he personally
built taimou a new pc
with a brand new mouse and keyboard
before watching him solo queue for
hours to prove that he wasn't cheating
over time the allegations just sort of
went away and taimou just continued
clapping kids in overwatch
he wasn't cheating he was just that good
like i never really care like i think
it's a take it as a compliment
coming in at number eight we have one of
the most shocking cheating accusations
in
cs go history the time someone dared to
call out
fallen three on two a five on two right
every single time
still winnable falling needs the ace
clutch he's got two
oh come on falling yeah the blood's
flowing now
oh he gets it the aids for fallen and my
goodness semi pr
back in 2016 at asl one cologne fallen
hit
an absolutely disgusting double with the
scouts and everyone was left scratching
their heads
about keeping their calm now and getting
that buddy system into effect they are
moving around in pairs not really
much room to work with but unless i what
can you do quality
race car comes right around the corner
and another headshot falling doing so
much work
it's it's a tragedy that liquid loses
that round when they have all the
advantages but it's a disaster that they
give over two ops for free now for most
cs players this just looked like fallen
hitting one of his normal god-like
shots but unfortunately this happened to
be around the same time that the
notorious boy who cried
cheetah dan m was accusing nearly every
pro
of cheating and that insane shot put
fallen in his crosshairs
like that movement is a very tiny
movement but the way it is
moving is extremely unhuman and
impossible
for him to do that move an l-shaped
movement with his mouth
most in that situation that quickly and
that perfectly
it's impossible it's exactly 90 degrees
as you can see
since then fallen has proven his skills
on land time and time again
and dan m just became a meme crisp
clean lock boys
flying into our number seven spot is
former shanghai dragons off tank
gegerie back in the early days of her
career gegerie's team
uw artisan took down team dizziness in a
nexus cup qualifier
after the match two members of the
losing team reported her to blizzard
south korea
for allegedly using an aimbot in this
part of game two
fortunately for gegary blizzard quickly
came out to clear her name
but not before one of the opposing
players literally sent her a death
threat
but if that wasn't enough to prove all
the hate is wrong gegary even set up a
stream with her keyboard and mouse in
view
and played for an entire hour to show
that she wasn't cheating
in the number six spot we've got built
by gamers resident silva main
critical this is just not worth the
effort keep that weapon into the next
round
allow time in to pick things up so
that's going to be putting time in with
an eighth round
slowly and surely we go
back in december 2020 bbg beat ninja's
valerant team
time in at the nights before christmas
tournament and it's safe to say that
ninja wasn't
too happy with the way his team lost
critical finished the series with a
whopping
plus 26 plus minus and after a clip
surfaced of him
allegedly locking on to an enemy player
built by gamers were disqualified from
the event
and ninja's team was set to move on to
the quarter-finals
then critical's teammate rob wiz came to
his defense releasing a twit longer
which suggested that ninja didn't have
any evidence to accuse critical with and
then
ninja fired back accusing critical of
cheating in the past
even though riot has cleared him before
eventually the tournament organizer gave
built by gamers their spot back in the
quarter finals but at that point they
didn't even want to play anymore
what an absolute [ __ ] show
coming in at our number five spot we've
got the man who single-handedly
destroyed the indian counter-strike
scene forsaken unfortunately it does
look like these issues are going to take
a little bit more
longer to fix than anticipated so we're
going to throw to a break don't go
anywhere in the game we'll be back
in august 2017 an indian organization
named team iatti posted allegations
against forsaken a couple of weeks after
losing to him
they watched back the demos and claimed
that they found some
fishy forsaken place and they even
managed to trace a somewhat recent
backband account to him despite the
allegations
optic india signed forsaken but we all
know how that turned out in a match
between
optic india and revolution vienne at the
extreme extremeland asian open
in 2018 forsaken sus play was on
center stage i don't i'm gonna have to
try and retake the site luckily there is
a hole in the smoke so the second's
gonna get some nice positioning on the
other side
during a technical pause the tournament
organizers decided to check his pc
and the rest is history admins found
cheats on forsaken's computer
poorly disguised as a file named
word.exe
which became the meme we know and loved
today forsaken was then hit with a
five-year ban and optic released their
entire indian roster
turns out some players are sus for a
reason
bragging his way onto the number four
spot we have cloud9's young balorant
star
leif before making the switch to
ballerin leaf was one of the most
exciting young
cs players around but in june 2020 his
team
chaos went up against mipr at cs summit
six
and leaf kind of popped off but now
leaf is stuck between rock and a hard
place
and uh those leaves on the ground making
him feel at home
not planning for him oh oh boy
he doesn't have a kiss either oh boy oh
my goodness
now they know that everything's going to
be in front of them but leaf the young
guy you're talking about
but we'll see this is a really cool
round for mvr you know last first round
of overtime just an app push
this is a good round for my brz they're
out this is what you want to blind that
guy from
his initial vision but how is he able to
get through there
they need to be scaling out of the
balcony that one guy big pit
and leaf just doing a great job but
after helping to take down some
brazilian cs
legends people started analyzing his
every move
suggesting that he might have cheated in
the match to make matters worse
even top players like fallen and tarik
suggested that the clips look suspicious
sending the brazilian fans into a frenzy
both of them apologized for speaking so
quickly
but at that point the damage was done
leaf was getting
death threats it's not really
in my right to do anything about it
and i definitely didn't mean for it to
blow up like this
like uh him getting death threats or
just like
the entire brazilian community just
throwing or like kind of overreacting i
guess it seems pretty unlikely that leaf
cheated
and after a few months things died down
apologies have been made
and these days leave his dumpster in
people invalid
he finds one on the way out as well just
down to leave but he can make this
costly
this is where reynolds are born this is
where reynolds are bred
one more yep now the duelists are
starting to come through
leave no way he gets the ace in the 10th
round for cloud9
jumping his way into the number three
spot we have cali
back in the day callie was one of the
most exciting cs go players around
but some people thought he might just be
too good
one clip in particular from esl one
cologne 2014
brought even more attention to his
suspicious play
i can't believe what i'm winning wow get
out of here
[Applause]
a few months after callie hit that
remarkable shot
he was hit with a vac ban and dropped by
titan
the following day he even admitted that
the ban was justified
because he used cheating software while
playing online for one week out of
curiosity
i i don't trust that seriously can you
call me that one
are you serious in my eyes no
callie hasn't seriously competed in cs
go in
years instead he runs a luxury car
rental service
and streams every once in a while but we
still don't know if he ever cheated on
land
in our runner-up spot we've got one of
the greatest players to ever grace
rainbow six siege shaiko shikoh has
always been an
absolute god when it comes to siege but
one match in september 2017
changed his life forever be genius is
basically just able to walk right in
and the first boat of contact a great
shot shiko what an unbelievable
kill on tunis there he hit some pretty
impressive shots against penta
but after the match his opponents asked
admins to look into whether or not
shaiko
cheated two weeks later esl released a
statement saying that their anti-cheat
software
found evidence of shaiko using a macro
and he was banned for two years without
a chance to appeal
scheikel has been banned from any esl
competitive play for two years
the any money any winnings that t b
genius has
accumulated throughout this season has
been forfeited as well as their spot in
this season of the pro league
scheiko's ban ended early thanks to his
good behavior and he got right back to
dunking on some of the best players in
the world
four versus four and we need to start
seeing that push come in from cavanaugh
we know the spots there but he peaks and
shaiko
it's just goddamn better brings down
sloth four
versus three oh my god he swings onto an
arc on the game wall
down he goes swings onto attic why is
this from scheiko four kills in the
round
doesn't need to make it the aces prelay
steps up still to this day people don't
know if shaiko
actually cheated during that fateful
game against penta
perhaps we'll never really know the
truth but what we do know is that these
days he's 100
legit and 100 lethal
in our top spot we have the undisputed
most sus player in all of esports
flusher
despite being a three-time major winner
flusha is one of csgo's most
controversial players
what is he even looking at there but
amongst his catalogue of fish he plays
there is one that trumps them all one
play that sparked more accusations than
any other he's still fully set up he
does catch a glimpse of one he gets the
tag he gets the kill
oh how the hell did he pull that off
that's two kills
i think he only even saw one of them but
he still made it work and devilwalk
holds on
look that play seems insane but flusha
has been competing on land for
over a decade calling his place doesn't
even
bother him anymore the other thing that
i want to ask you about is
you're you're you're a person who who's
dealt with criticism very well i feel
like you've um
you you take it in good stride last year
when there were lots of accusations
going around
what was that like i carried a little a
little more like
when than i do now but it's been like
this for the most part of my
cs career i guess so i couldn't really
give up there's no hard evidence that
flusher has ever cheated
or evidence that he hasn't but at this
point it's safe to assume he isn't
cheating
maybe he's just too good well those were
the most sus
plays that we could find for you did we
miss out any better ones though
let us know also let us know what you
want to see next on the channel
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
oh my god i'm stupid dude
wait what the [ __ ] clara
hold on clara give me one second clara
let me just message this girl give me
one second why is this on my computer
right now